wir alle haben diese Bilder gesehen Ende
Juli und Anfang Juli herrschte in
Frankreich wieder einmal mehrere Tage
lang das totale Chaos die Bilder der
Proteste Plünderungen Brände und
Krawalle die in Frankreichs Großstädten
ausbrachen gingen um die Welt natürlich
sind diese Bilder für die Grand Nation
nichts Außergewöhnliches mehr Ereignisse
und Bilder die mehr oder weniger ähnlich
sind wiederholen sich immer wieder und
mit zunehmender Intensität dabei spielt
es keine Rolle ob es sich um
rassistische oder religiöse Proteste um
das Finale der Champions League um die
geldwesten oder um Rentenreformen
handelt Gewalt dazu einem
charakteristischen Merkmal jeder
sozialen Bewegung in diesem Land die
jüngste Welle von Unruhen die durch den
tödlichen Schuss eines Polizisten auf
eine 17-Jährigen verkehrsfrau die
algerische Herkunft ausgelöst wurde
würde dazu dass mehr als 5000 Fahrzeuge
verbrannt mehr als 1000 Häuser
beschädigt oder geplündert hat 269
Polizeistation angegriffen und mehr als
4000 Menschen festgenommen wurden es war
der blanke Wahnsinn dennoch sollten wir
uns nichts vormachen wenn diese Proteste
werden nicht die letzten und auch nicht
die größten gewesen sein
[Musik]
in der Geschichte des postmoderm
Frankreich werden Sie nicht mehr als
eine kleine Fußnote darstellen fast
schon einen routinevorgang im heutigen
Frankreich ist auch die jüngste Welle
der Gewalt genau das die letzte Welle
vor der nächsten die schon in nicht
allzu ferner Zukunft kommen wird es ist
etwas das unweigerlich und scheinbar
unaufhaltsam passieren wird und es wird
wahrscheinlich schneller passieren als
wir es uns vorstellen können denn
Frankreich meine verehrten visualpolitik
Zuschauer beginnt zu zerbrechen das Land
droht ernsthaft zu implodieren und immer
wieder geht es in Flammen auf es ist als
Frankreich ein Druckkochtopf jede Krise
Offenbach Spannungen einen Konflikt in
der Gesellschaft unser Land beruflich
ständig auf republikanische Werte aber
es scheint das ganze Teil der
Bevölkerung nicht das Gefühl haben dass
dies für Sie von Bedeutung sei die
Situation hat einen solchen Punkte
erreicht dass der französische Präsident
immer noch immer während der Proteste so
weit gegen Ideen wie die Folgen dazu
befürworten macron schlägt vor soziale
Medien während der Unruhen zu sperren
aber was genau ist in Frankreich
eigentlich los warum scheint die
Gesellschaft völlig zerrüttet zu sein
was verbirgt sich hinter diesen
gewaltigen Wellen der Gewalt welche
Folgen werden sich voraussichtlich haben
und könnte eine ähnliche Entwicklung
auch anderen Ländern drohen die sich auf
demselben Weg befinden wie Frankreich
meine Lieben Zuschauer in diesem Video
werden wir die drei Hauptfaktoren
benennen für das Chaos das in Frankreich
immer wieder ausbricht die drei
wichtigsten Gründe deren Verständnis ist
unser ermöglichen wird das Gesamtbild
dessen zu erfassen was genau in
Frankreich eigentlich vor sich geht noch
wir werden es nicht bei theoretischen
Erörterungen belassen sondern euch
knallhartes Zahlenmaterial liefern das
genau belegt warum Paris und andere
französische Großstädte zu den Gotham
citys Europas werden das Problem in
diesem Fall ist weit und breit kein
Batman in Sicht obwohl wir sehen werden
einige Figuren so tun als wären sie
Batman oder Batman ein echter Retter in
der Not und zwar der Not des
steuergeldes ist übrigens der Sponsor
unseres heutigen Videos und der heißt
ganz passend Steuerbord wusstest du das
Millionen Deutsche Steuer weil er jedes
Jahr viel Geld verschenken nur weil sie
durch die komplexe steuerbürokratie
abgeschreckt werden dabei würde er sich
durchaus lohnen sich mal zu überwinden
schließlich haben laut Statistischen
Bundesamt im vergangenen Jahr 12,3
Millionen Menschen eine Steuererstattung
bekommen und zwar im Schnitt 1272 Euro
so aber wie wäre es wenn man sich gar
nicht überwinden müsste und die
Steuererstattung trotzdem einstreichen
könnte wie nun natürlich mit Steuerbord
und so unglaublich dies klingt mit der
steuerbord-app Macht die Steuererklärung
sogar richtig Spaß wenn ihre Macke haben
diese nützliche App nicht nur mit jeder
Menge steuern auch voll gestoppt sondern
auch mit einer gehörigen Portion Humor
mit der sie die abstruse
steuerbürokratie gehörig auf Korn nehmen
Steuerbord ist quasi sowas wie Chichi
mit einem steuerberatungsblatt in das
während es locker mit ihr plaudert im
Hintergrund schon mal deine
Steuererklärung ausfüllt und optimiert
Steuerbord führt dich durch alle
notwendigen Angaben so als würde man
über WhatsApp mit einem gewissen
Steuerberater chatten und innerhalb von
20 Minuten ist die Steuererklärung
fertig
Übermittlung ans Finanzamt bereit
komplett papierlos und digital es ist
von deiner Seite kein steuerwissen
erforderlich und du kannst dabei keine
Fehler machen auch für absolute
steuerleinwand auf diese Weise die
Steuererklärung und eine eventuell
saftige Steuererstattung zum Klacks und
sollte es notwendig sein unterstützt
sich auch der fachkundige menschliche
Support bei Steuerbord jederzeit mit
garantierten Antwortzeiten innerhalb von
24 Stunden das beste falls du deine
Steuererklärung der letzte Jahre noch
nicht eingereicht hast kannst du das mit
Steuerbord Rückwirkung erledigen
Steuerbord erledigt wirklich alles für
dich du musst dich nicht mit dem
Finanzamt auseinandersetzen alles was du
brauchst ist deine
Lohnsteuerbescheinigung und schon kann
es losgehen ganz einfach auf den Link in
der Videobeschreibung oder nutze den QR
Codes einblenden denn damit erhältst du
sogar noch 10 € Rabatt also worauf
wartest du noch du deinem Geldbeutel
etwas Gutes und fahren jetzt gleich an
so einfach steuern zu sparen wie nie
zuvor vielleicht kommt dabei ja genug
herum dass du damit auch unsere Arbeit
finanziell unterstützen kannst den
Spenden Link dazu findest du übrigens
ebenfalls in der Beschreibung unter dem
Video so und wenn du das alles erledigt
hast lass uns wieder ins turbulente
Gallien zurückkehren um zu ergründen was
da eigentlich alles schief gelaufen ist
aufgepasst
[Musik]
der soziale branza
und diese ganze Geschichte wirklich
verstehen zu können müssen wir zunächst
in die Mitte des 20 Jahrhunderts reisen
wie viele andere Metropolen in Europa
und Amerika wuchsen auch Paris und
andere französische Großstädte mit
großer Geschwindigkeit die
Industrialisierung und die Abwanderung
vom Land in die Stadt führten zu einer
Vervielfachung der Stadtbevölkerung im
Falle Frankreich wurde dieses Phänomen
auch durch die Entkolonialisierung des
ehemaligen Kaiserreichs beschleunigt
als Reaktion auf der Überfüllung der
Städte und das entstehen riesige
Elendsviertel und warten Siedlungen aus
weltlich und Pappe wie man sie aus der
Dritten Welt kennt begann man in den
1960er Jahren an den Ränder der
Großstädte riesige moderne vor
ortsiedlungen in Plattenbauweise zu
errichten die Rede ist von den berühmten
sie entstanden überall in Paris
Marseille und anderen Großstädten ihr
bauvorzog sich unter der Leitung des
französischen Staates der damit begann
tausende und aber tausend
Jahrzehntausende von Sozialwohnungen in
diesen neuen Vierteln zu fördern er
errichtete dort natürlich auch Schulen
medizinische Zentrum und öffentliche
Verkehrslinien auf dem Papier handelt es
sich um eine fantastische Idee
mit diesen neuen Stadtvierteln und den
Tausenden von Sozialwohnungen die von
der Regierung gebaut wurden wurden die
ersten Bewohner Frankreichs nicht nur
aus ihren Elendsvierteln herausgeholt
und bekamen eine ordentliche moderne
Wohnung sondern ermöglichte ihn auch an
einem wesentlichen wohlhabenden
Lebensstil teil zu haben doch schon bald
traten Probleme auf wie ihr wisst klappt
zwischen Theorie und Praxis oft eine
gewaltige Lücke und ihr wisst ebenso gut
dass gute Absichten noch lange keine
guten Ergebnisse garantieren
ursprünglich war der größte Teil der
Wohnungen für Franzosen bestimmt die vom
Land in die Stadt ausgewandert waren
aber sobald diese die Möglichkeit dazu
hatten zogen sie wieder in Viertel die
als besser angesehen wurden und was
geschah dann mit den frei gewordenen
Sozialwohnungen nun sie wurden von der
eingewanderten Bevölkerung bezogen bzw
mit der Zeit regelrecht eingenommen
gleichzeitig hatte die
Industrialisierung die Paris in den
letzten Jahrzehnten erlebt hat vielen
Bewohnern dieser Stadtteile die Türen zu
guten Arbeitsplätzen und guten Gehältern
verschlossen und so wurden diese
Gegenden zu einer Aktionen für Armut
viel geschlagene Integrationen alle
möglichen Probleme Schulabbrecher
Diskriminierung Arbeitslosigkeit
verfallende Gebäude Kriminalität sagen
wir einfach dass diese Vorstände nach
und nach zu echten Ghettos wurden
dies war ein besonders intensives
Phänomen für viele Gruppen von
Einwanderern aus der Karibik dem seneg
Alter Elfenbeinküste Marokko und vor
allem Algerien sie alle leben in
separierten Viertel in denen der
kulturelle Druck ihre Herkunftsländer
aufrecht erhalten wird und in denen der
Grad der Integration in die französische
Gesellschaft relativ gering ist und als
ob das alles nicht schon schlimm genug
wäre sind in den letzten Jahren z.B noch
viele Menschen Ausländern wie Pakistan
oder Tschetschenien zugewandert wie ihr
euch vorstellen könnt ist die
Kombination solche starre altertümliche
Kulturen mit einer getuisierung eine
tickende Zeitung
aber glaub bitte nicht dass diese
Tatsache irgendjemanden überrumpelt
hätte schon 1977 war die französische
Regierung besorgt darüber dass ich
überall Ghettos bilden
[Musik]
deswegen hat der französische Staat
allein in den letzten 20 Jahren satte 60
Milliarden Euro für eine kolossale
Kampagne zur Renovierung von Wohnblocks
zu Verbesserung der Infrastruktur und
zur Aufwertung aller Arten von
Einrichtungen in diesen Vierteln
ausgegeben diese Mittel wurden
insbesondere auf die ärmsten Gegenden
konzentriert in denen heute mehr als 5
Millionen Menschen leben die hätte davon
stammt aus Algerien mit den vielen Geld
wurden für diese Menschen reichhaltige
soziale Angebote geschaffen und
großzügige öffentliche Einrichtungen
errichtet wie Bibliotheken Schulen und
Gesundheitszentren und wie ihr während
der jüngsten Proteste sicher alle
gesehen habt waren es genau diese
Bibliotheken Schulen und
Gesundheitszentren die vom wütenden Mob
angegriffen und niedergebrannt wurden
warum nun ganz einfach weil sie
existierten und von den Randalierern
kulturell abgelehnt ja verachtet werden
sie sind mit ihrer Welt und ihren
Wertvorstellungen und vereinbar die
Gesundheitsversorgung ist kostenlos die
Schule ist kostenlos und manchmal haben
wir das Gefühl dass es nie genug ist
die kommen ja von Menschen denen sie die
Schuld an ihrer eigenen Misere geben
darüber hinaus gibt es seit Jahren eine
Vielzahl von Organisationen die von der
Regierung bezahlt werden und versuchen
die Dinge zu verbessern doch trotz aller
Bemühungen sind die Ergebnisse eher
dürftig die Bolly sind weiterhin bekannt
für ihre hohe Arbeitslosigkeit
Schulabbrecherquote Drogenabhängigkeit
Armut und Kriminalität es ist eine echte
Katastrophe aber es ist nun mal die
Umgebung in der diese Leute ihre
Sozialisation gefunden haben wenn man
die so nennen kann denn viele der
Menschen die in diesen Orten leben
insbesondere Kinder haben es nicht
leicht diesen Zuständen zu entkommen sie
sind durch ihre Herkunft und ihren
Wohnort zum Beispiel bei der
Arbeitsplatzsuche regelrecht gebrannt
Markt und die Wahrheit ist nun mal das
ist relativ einfach ist materielle Dinge
zu verändern alles was der Stadt tun
muss ist sein checkbuch zu gucken wenn
es sie doch um Kulturwerte das Wesen die
Haltung und Überzeugungen von Menschen
geht wird es schon verdammt viel
schwieriger wollt ihr einen konkretes
Beispiel nun nehmen wir mal die Schulen
die Schulen in diesen Vierteln haben
sehr hohe Durchfallquoten und das
Bildungsniveau des Umfeld jede Schülers
es tendenziell viel niedriger als im
Rest des Landes damit haben es dann auch
die Lehrer viel schwerer etwas
aufzubauen und zu ändern die Vorbilder
und Leitwerte der Kinder und
Jugendlichen sind ganz andere als
außerhalb der riesigen Problemviertel
und das bedeutet dass viele Schüler am
Ende auf der Strecke bleiben keinerlei
Chance haben mental auch nur ein Fußball
in der modernen Leistungsgesellschaft
anzukommen
[Musik]
diese Erfahrungen und diese Lebensweise
geben Sie den auch an ihre Kinder weiter
deren Zahl dank islamisch patriarchaler
Werte in Verbindung mit üppiges
Sozialhilfe nicht gering ausfällt und
damit wäre der Generation übergreifende
Teufelskreis geschlossen tatsache ist
nun mal dass die Politik des
öffentlichen Wohnungsbaus in Frankreich
zur Bildung echter Ghettos wie aus dem
Lehrbuch geführt hat in denen auch noch
Menschen aus archiatischen Kulturen
konzentriert und somit konserviert
wurden ganz genau was eigentlich als
progressive Politik gemeint war führte
zu einem
hyperkonservativen Albtraum das
allgemeine Unverständnis von
progressivismus und Konservativismus und
die beide ineinander greifen ist einer
der Hauptfaktoren der erklärt warum
Frankreich so viele Probleme mit der
Integration von einwandern hat im Grunde
kommen die Einwanderer nach Frankreich
sie leben in Frankreich ihre Kinder
werden in Frankreich geboren aber sie
werden nie wirklich zu Franzosen weder
sie noch ihre Kinder noch ihre Kinder
zumindest nicht vollständig nicht so wie
es ein zivilisiertes zusammenleben
diesem erfordern würde und dass mein
Leben Zuschauer ist kein populistischer
kulturpessionismus oder Panik mache die
Daten sprechen eine klare Sprache so
wird geschätzt dass etwa 50% der Kinder
in diesen Ghettos arm sind die
Arbeitslosigkeit ist fast doppelt so
hoch wie im Landesdurchschnitt und die
Familieneinkommen sind natürlich viel
niedriger jeder Fünfte in Frankreich
lebende Ausländer fühlt sich aufgrund
seiner Herkunft seiner Rasse oder seine
Religion diskriminiert wohlgemerkt das
ist kein Spaß keine Nebensächlichkeit
bei der man irgendwie wieder zur
Tagesordnung zurückkehren könnte es
handelt sich um eine der höchsten Quoten
in der entwickelten Welt meine echte
tickende Zeitbombe die Zahlen zeigen
deutlich dass Frankreich zu den Ländern
gehört die die größten Probleme mit der
Integration von Einwanderern haben und
all diese Probleme konzentrieren sich
vor allem in diesen Vororten des
kulturellen
und dann schaut euch einfach mal diese
Grafik an
in diesen Viertel herrscht immer noch
das Gefühl und wahrscheinlich auch die
Realität dass man nicht so viele
Möglichkeiten hat wie in anderen
Gegenden wenn man sieht wie seine Eltern
und älteren Geschwister um Arbeit
kämpfen wir zahlen für die Konzentration
der Armut die mangelnde Vielfalt in den
Schulen und die Weigerung außerhalb
dieser Viertel Sozialwohnungen zu bauen
all diese Faktoren führen logischerweise
zu Frustration und täuscht euch nicht
Frustration ist der bestmögliche
Treibstoff für Gewalt
erschwerend kommt hinzu das sind diesen
Vierteln in den letzten Jahren zwei neue
Probleme aufgetreten sind erstens
Drogenhandel
kokain-angebot in Frankreich so hoch wie
nie der Drogenkonsum in Frankreich hat
in den letzten Jahren stark zugenommen
man schätzt das ist in Frankreich allein
600.000 regelmäßige Konsumenten von
Kokain gibt und das hat natürlich zu
Entstehung zahlreicher unterweltgruppen
geführt die genau und diesen Viertel aus
operieren gleichzeitig gibt es das
Problem des religiösen Fundamentalismus
gerade in solchen Vorstädten lebt der
größte Teil der muslimischen Bevölkerung
Frankreichs und man bedenke dass der
Mangel an Chancen das Gefühl nicht dazu
zu gehören und die Frustration den
perfekten Nährboden für die Rekrutierung
von Fanatikern gebildet haben ich weiß
nicht ob ihr euch noch daran erinnern
könnt aber vor der Pandemie waren sie
hat distische Anschläge in Frankreich an
der Tagesordnung nun die meisten davon
wurden natürlich von Mustern und ratet
mal wo die gelebt haben genau in den
bonnie ist glücklicherweise gab es im
letzten Jahren keine großarten mehr die
von diesen Menschen ausgehende Gewalt
ist jedoch in weniger stark organisierte
Formen wie messerkriminalität
übergegangen und auch wenn diese
international nicht mehr für so große
Schlagzeilen sorgt vor dass sie dennoch
unzählige Opfer und das alles hat
logischerweise zu einer enormen Spirale
des Misstrauens der Gewalt und des
Argwohns beigetragen die das
Grundproblem nur noch verschärft hat
Menschen ausländische Herkunft die
diesen Viertel leben willst zum Beispiel
nicht nur niemand einstellen nein sie
werden z.B auch 20 Mal häufiger von der
Polizei kontrolliert klar diese hohe
Kontrolle und fahndungsintensität ist
dann wohl auch dafür verantwortlich dass
es eben nicht mehr zu groß Anschlägen
und Massakern gekommen ist auf der
anderen Seite hat sie jedoch auch eine
negativen Effekt stellt euch mal vor ihr
seid ein unbescholtener Moslem aus den
Bonus und trotzdem werdet ihr dank eures
Wohnorts eure Hautfarbe und eurer nicht
ganz so ungeschulte Nachbarn und
Glaubensbrüder 20 mal öfter von der
Polizei kontrolliert und verdächtigt als
der Rest der Franzosen was meint ihr was
das nach einiger Zeit gar nach Jahren
und Jahrzehnten mit einem macht
vergessen bitte nicht dass die Polizei
in Frankreich nicht immer besonders
freundlich und zimperlich vorgeht ja
eine weitere psychologischer
Teufelskreis aus dem es scheinbar kein
Entkommen gibt und das bringt uns direkt
zum zweiten wichtigen Faktor in dieser
Geschichte Hörzu
die Polizei der Brandbeschleuniger
bevor wir uns dem zweiten wichtigen
Faktor zuwenden würde ich euch gerne
darauf aufmerksam machen dass wir
endlich einen discord Server für euch
unsere Community eröffnet haben dort
könnt ihr nicht nur über Themen rund um
unsere Videos diskutieren sondern uns
auch Anregungen geben über was wir in
Zukunft sprechen sollen daneben gibt es
doch die Möglichkeit sich einfach frei
auszutauschen und sich unsere Videos
vorab anzusehen so könnt ihr uns schon
vor ihrer Veröffentlichung auf etwaige
Fehler hinweisen wir hoffen auf diese
Weise mit eurer Hilfe eine noch höhere
Qualität erreichen zu können also schaut
jetzt gleich auf unsere neuen discords
verwandeln vorbei den Link dazu findet
ihr in der Beschreibung unter diesem
Video und nun zurück nach Frankreich und
zum zweiten Faktor der dortigen Misere
der unglücklichen Rolle der Polizei die
Polizei ist bei weitem eine der
mächtigsten Institutionen Frankreichs
unter anderem deshalb weil sie sehr
stark gewerkschaftlich organisiert ist
die Polizei verfügt über großen
politischen Einfluss ohne den letzten
Jahren haben der Aufstieg
designalistischen Fundamentalismus die
immer häufigeren Proteste gegen die
aktuelle Regierung und die Zunahme des
Drogenhandels ihre Präsenz in der
Gesellschaft doch verstärkt um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben von immer
weiter steigender Kriminalität und
Terrorgefahr getrieben hat Frankreich
seit Anfang des Jahrtausends praktisch
jedes Jahr ein neues Sicherheitsgesetz
verabschiedet dass die Polizei stärkt so
können Sie zum Beispiel bei ihren
Patrouillen in den Vorstädten
routinemäßig zwischenwaffen einsetzen
also nicht tödliche Waffen wie Taser und
Schlagstöcke was im übrigen Europa
äußerst selten ist ein anderes Beispiel
die Polizei hat die Befugnis erhalten
jede beliebige Person ohne jeglichen
Grund und ohne vorherigen Verdacht
anzuhalten und zu identifizieren zu den
neuen Befugnissen gehört auch dass die
Verkehrspolizei seit 2017 gegen jeden
Fahrer der vor einer Kontrolle fliegt
tödliche Gewalt anwenden darf und auch
wenn es Euch überraschen mag so war der
Fall ist ein ganz Athleten jungen
Algerien jetzt nach helmersog bei Leibe
kein Einzelfall am 7 Junior drei Wochen
vorne heißt tot erschoss die Pariser
Polizei auch eine junge Frau 21 Jahre
alt die sich angeblich geweigert hatte
an einem Kontrollpunkt anzuhalten am 14
Juni zwei Wochen vor einer Hals tot
tötete die Polizei an einem anderen kon
trollpunkt auch einen 19-Jährigen
lieferarbeiter einen Jungen aus Guinea
insgesamt hatte die französische Polizei
den 18 Monaten vor dem Vorfall der die
Proteste auslöstete 17 Menschen bei
Verkehrskontrollen getötet
und das ist noch nicht alles unabhängig
von diesen Extremfällen bei denen sogar
Menschen umkommen steigt die Zahl der
Beschwerden aufgrund von
verschiedenartigster
kompetenzüberschreitungen der Polizist
und Gendarmen natürlich macht sie das
vor allem in den Vororten sehr unbeliebt
und das beruht auf Gegenseitigkeit
Umfragen zu Folge identifizieren sich
französische Polizeibeamte
überproportional mit Parteien wie den
National von Marine die eine viel
härtere Gangart fordert tatsächlich
haben die beiden großen
polizeigesellschaften nach den jüngsten
Unruhen einen äußerst hetzerischen Ton
angeschlagen sie gingen sogar so weit zu
sagen dass sie sich im Krieg gegen Horn
von wilden befinden und den erraten das
Handwerk legen müssten nun ja was soll
man dazu noch sagen es ist klar dass die
Nerven auch auf Seiten der Polizei blank
liegen aber die Gewerkschaft da könnten
ihre Meinung über die unzumutbaren
Zustände auch formulieren ohne auf Enten
menschlichen zurückzugreifen mit solchen
Aussagen verlassen sie nicht nur den
Vater der Zivilisation nein diese sind
auch extrem kontraproduktiv und
polarisieren heizen die Stimmung nur
noch weiter an aber mit der
französischen Polizei ist nun mal nicht
zu spaßen und das bekommt selbst der
Präsident zu spüren ja ganz genau die
Polizei scheint selbst seiner Kontrolle
zu entgleiten hört euch mal an was
macron im Jahr 2017 gesagt hat ich
möchte die Kultur den Führungsstil und
die Rekrutierung der Polizei ändern und
was ist daraus geworden nun macron hatte
keinerlei Chancen denn nur kurz darauf
kamen die geldwesten die Proteste gegen
die Rentenreform und so weiter eine
Krise nach der anderen in denen es sich
der Präsident einfach nicht leisten
konnte sich auch noch mit der Polizei
Lobby anzulegen und schon gar nicht mit
den mächtigen Gewerkschaften es wäre
wirklich das Letzte gewesen was er in
dieser Situation brauchte und die
Tatsache dass die Polizei nicht in der
Lage ist die Vororte unter Kontrolle zu
halten und dass die Bevölkerung diesen
Vierteln so wenig Vertrauen in sie hat
verschärft natürlich noch weiter das
Problem der Ghettoisierung dass wir
bereits gesehen haben schon wieder ein
Teufelskreis und schon wieder nur
Verlierer weit und breit eine
gigantische luce
und für alle Beteiligten und alle Teile
der Gesellschaft aber wartete Moment
dieser ganzen Geschichte gibt es eine
ganz bestimmte Gruppe die alles andere
als am verlieren ist im Gegenteil der
dritte große Faktor in diesem ganzen
Schlamassel entpuppt sich als der große
Nutznießer der französischen Misere na
seid ihr gespannt von wem hier die Rede
ist dann aufgepasst
der Ruf nach einer eisernen Faust und
seine Folgen
die jüngste Welle der Gewalt hat eine
klare Siegerin hervorgebracht Marine Le
Pen die Franzosen haben allmählich die
Nase voll und lepin hat die Gunst der
Stunde genutzt wie keine andere Lippen
und ihrer Partei nutzen die Unruhen um
die Regierung macron unter Druck zu
setzen aber auch um ein Paket harter
Maßnahmen zu präsentieren die der
Mehrheit der Villa gefallen sollen der
rassom limonational ehemals braun
national also auf Deutsch sowas wie die
nationale Sammlungsbewegung ist die
parteilotenz sie möchte z.B das
Jugendliche ab 16 Jahren wie Erwachsene
vor Gericht gestellt werden können sie
will dass diejenigen die wegen einer
Straftat verurteilt werden das Recht
verlieren in öffentlichen Wohnungen zu
wohnen oder irgendeine Art von
Sozialhilfe oder Leistung vom Staat zu
erhalten sie fordert auch das viel mehr
Menschen im Gefängnis landen und dass
die Sozialleistungen für Menschen die in
den berüchtigten Vorstädten Leben
gekürzt werden und wisst ihr was all das
fängt angesichts der unhaltbaren sich
immer weiter verschlimmernden Zustände
der Ausweglosigkeit und des
augenscheinlichen zerfallen in den Ohren
der französischen wähl verdammt gut zu
klingen und nein wir sind nicht die
einzigen die das behaupten am 30 Juni
wurde eine Umfrage durchgeführt aus der
hervorging das lepenzvorschläge im
Vergleich mit den aller anderen
politischen Führer Frankreichs von den
Wählern am besten bewertet werden der
Abschaum den wir beim Plündern von
Geschäften beim Anzünden von
Bibliotheken und Rathäusern sehen
während er lacht tut dies nicht für nach
hell es ist ein Vorwand um die Polizei
und alles was die Republik repräsentiert
anzugreifen ganz genau im Großen Meer
der Trost und Hilflosigkeit der
französischen Politik Stellen
ausgerechnet lepenzlösungsansätze für
die meisten Franzosen das geringste Übel
da
[Musik]
es ist der Offenbarungseid einer Nation
die sich über Jahrzehnte sehenden Auges
in die Sackgasse manövriert hat
wohlgemerkt eine Sackgasse an deren Ende
sich ein Abgrund befindet und keinerlei
Wendemöglichkeit alles was bleibt ist
der Rückwärtsgang in dem angesichts der
allgemeinen politischen Nackenstarre
jegliche sensible navigation
möglich ist es wird so oder so eine
extrem holprige Fahrt mit ungewissem
Ausgang oder Preis für einen ballerfolg
für Pens könnte sehr hoch sein ein Pakt
mit dem Teufel weil man sich alle
anderen Alternativen beraubt hat führte
noch nie ins Paradies denn eines darf
man nicht vergessen so verlockend sein
Lösungsangebot für die dringendsten
Probleme auch klingen mag es ist immer
mit dem kleinen gedruckten verbunden Le
Pen mag die Franzosen eventuell von der
Gefahr und den Elend einer ungezügelten
Islamisierung befreien aber sie wird sie
wohl gleichzeitig bzw nach und nach auch
von vielen ur-französischen
demokratischen Werten befreien fakt ist
nach den jüngsten Ausschreitungen hat
nicht nur die Polizei bei den
franzosenstärker bekommen sondern auch
Maßnahmen zur Einschränkung der
bürgerlichen Freiheiten und Rechte laut
einer von der Zeitung veröffentlichten
Umfrage stellten sich 57% auf die Seite
der Polizei während sage und schreibe
69% gar nicht Verhängung des
Ausnahmezustand befürworteten was
übrigens eine weitere Forderungen war
und die folgende Nachricht zeigt Klick
und was die Franzosen wirklich Denken
und Wollen
Spendenaktion für französischen
offizielle Teenager tötete bringt über
1,5 Millionen Euro ein genau das ist
also der Nährboden der gerade in
Frankreich entsteht und ihr wisst ganz
genau für was dies der Nährboden ist
noch mehr Polarisationen noch mehr
Extremismus dafür immer weniger Freiheit
Demokratie und Pluralismus auf der einen
Seite stehen die frustrierten der
Vorstädte die sich mit ihrer
anachronistischen Kultur unter kräftige
Unterstützung die realistische Kräfte
zum Beispiel aus Saudi-Arabien oder der
Türkei selbst abgehängt haben sie haben
den Anschluss an die humanistische
moderne verloren und geben dafür auch
noch gehen die Schuld die sie mal in ihr
Land aufgenommen haben wir haben über
die extrem Gefahren des radikalen Islam
in Frankreich und seine Unterstützer aus
dem Namen Osten sogar mal ein eigenes
Video gedreht das leider von Youtube
demontisiert wurde aber ich werde euch
trotzdem verlinken oder die gemäßigten
Kräfte unfähig sind die islamische
Radikalisierung einzudämmen werden auf
der anderen Seite als größte Nutznießer
die radikalsten nationalistischen
Parteien mit voller Kraft um
Unterstützung das Ergebnis ist die
Eliminierung der demokratischen Mitte
und mit ihr die extrem große Gefahr
einer Implosion Frankreichs es scheint
wie die Wahl zwischen Pest oder Cholera
zu sein zwischen dem Abrutschen in den
rechtsextreme nationalistischen
Autoritarismus oder die schleichende
Unterwerfung im totalitär islamischen
Kalifat ja die entsprechenden Parteien
stehen auch auf der letzteren Seite
schon in den Startlöchern aber Moment
mal gibt es denn wirklich keinerlei
Perspektive für moderne europäische
Werte mehr ist Frankreich wirklich schon
verloren wird es unweigerlich so enden
wieder Iran der einst liberale Libanon
Syrien oder vielleicht wie neuerdings
auch die Türkei nun fakt ist das
Frankreich war viel Aufmerksamkeit zum
Teil wird es in Europa aber beileibe
kein Einzelfall lässt
[Musik]
andere Länder wie Belgien und
Deutschland haben sich ebenfalls in
diese Pipeline eingereiht das Thema
Einwanderung und vor allem die
Integrationsprobleme die zu vielen der
in den letzten Jahrzehnten
durchgeführten Maßnahmen geführt haben
sind in der Tat brisante und die
zahlreichen Tabus ob selbst aufgestellt
oder durch kampfbegriffe wie
Islamophobie von äußere Propaganda
importiert behindern eine konstruktive
Lösung in starkem Maße hier auch
visualpolitik haben wir bereits darüber
berichtet dass auch schon weden
ernsthafte Problem mit eingewanderter
Gewalt hat dort hat die Polizei z.B mehr
als 30.000 Personen als Auslosung von
Gewalt im Land identifiziert sie sind
entweder Teil von mehr als 50 Banken
oder haben enge Verbindungen zu ihm wir
hatten es noch nie mit einer der Arzt
krupellosen Kriminalität zu tun das
Organisationsmodell des gesamten
schwedischen Justizsystems ist nicht
darauf vorbereitet mit einer derart
unfassbaren Kriminalität umzugehen
ähnliche Entwicklung und vollziehen sich
mit wachsenden Tempo auch in Belgien
oder sogar Deutschland dort hat er
Anstieg der Straftaten und die
offensichtliche Erosion einer
natürlichen öffentlichen Ordnung
wohlgemerkt einer natürlichen von
Mitmenschen ausgehen denn nicht durch
Polizei und Security erzwungenen Ordnung
dazu geführt dass immer mehr Wähler in
Kauf nehmen dass die einst als
konservative Wirtschaftspartei
angetreten AFD mittlerweile in starkem
Maße von rechts wie linksextremen
Kräften unterwandert ist hauptsache sie
bietet Ihnen einigermaßen sinnvoll
klingende Ansätze zur Lösung speziell
dieser Probleme fakt ist die vor allem
von Linken oder nach links gerückten
pseudokonservativen Parteien
vorangetriebene Politik der offenen
Grenzen der lässt sehr Integration und
der bedingungslosen materiellen
Versorgung von Einwanderern ist
gescheitert
[Musik]
insgesamt sind von den 27 Regierungen
der Europäischen Union derzeit nur sechs
linksorientiert und es könnten bald doch
weniger werden in den letzten 18 Monaten
hat sich in ganz Europa politischer
wandelvollzogen dabei spielt die
Zuwanderung und vor allem die
Integrationsproblematik eine ganz
wesentliche Rolle selbst die schwedische
Sozialdemokratie die quasi in letzter
Minute noch reumütlich eine Kehrtwende
in ihre Migrationspolitik hingelegt hat
konnte sich damit nicht vor dem Zorn der
Wähler retten und wurde aus der
Regierung [__] und auch wenn ihre
Einsicht viel zu spät kamen so ist genau
dies unserer Meinung nach der richtige
Ansatz um extreme Situation und
Entwicklung in den Griff zu bekommen
oder von vornherein zu vermeiden ist es
eben notwendig auch etwas härterer der
eigene Natur erstmal widerstrebende
Schritte zu ergreifen wenn sie dazu
dienen wieder ein gesundes
gesellschaftliches Gleichgewicht
herzustellen denn wenn die Gesellschaft
in Schieflage gerät oder so geraten
droht muss man eben manchmal auch mehr
fordern als fördern und man musste hier
zur notwendigen Forderungen auch
konsequent und systematisch durchsetzen
auch wenn dabei die ideologischen
Idealvorstellungen erst einmal hinten
angestellt werden müssen es sind eben
nicht alle Menschen von Natur aus gut
sonst würde sowas wie Kommunismus sehr
Funktionieren der Mensch braucht die
richtigen wohlkalibrierten Anreize er
braucht nun Zeit zu Zeit auch den gut
gemeinten sprichwörtlichen Arschtritt
und die Gesellschaft braucht ihre piekse
die erst ihre Wundheilung in Gang setzen
erst wenn alle anderen Misere
Beteiligten auf den Boden der nackten
Tatsachen heruntergeholt werden haben
Sie die Chance auf die langsame
Ausrichtung aus dem Rausch ihrer Traum
und Parallelwelten
wie macron junge Randalierer stoppen
will Mama und Papa sollen für Ordnung
sorgen die Unruhe in Frankreich haben
eine Debatte darüber ausgelöst ob Eltern
für die Schäden die junge Randalierer
anrichten verantwortlich gemacht werden
sollten solche korrektiven Schritte und
Maßnahmen dürfen durch die
demokratischen Kräfte in der Mitte der
Gesellschaft daher nicht ab priori
ausgeschlossen werden nur weil sie auch
von radikalen Parteien gefordert werden
und man darf sie auch nicht mit
Totschlagargumenten wie den berüchtigten
Nazi und islamophobiekeulen tabuisieren
toleranz kann es demnächstes paradox
sonst und dann geben wenn man die
intoleranten nicht toleriert wichtig ist
aber eben dass die Toleranz erhaltene
Intoleranz gegen den intoleranten von
ihnen Kräften umgesetzt wird die
grundsätzlich eine demokratische
freiheitliche Agenda verfolgen dies gilt
für alle Bereiche von Gesellschaft und
Politik egal ob es sich um Migration und
Integration Bildung arbeite Rente und
Sozialhilfe Wirtschaft und Energie oder
außen und Sicherheitspolitik handelt die
eiserne Faust ist eben manchmal
notwendig sie sollte jedoch nur von
ihnen gesprungen werden die wirklich
verantwortungsvoll mit dir um können
jenen den sie eigentlich zuwider ist
Ordnung Ordnung macron forderte Rückkehr
zur Autorität nach den Unruhen in
Frankreich wegen des Todes von erhell
die Lehre die ich daraus ziehe lautet
Ordnung Ordnung es muss Ordnung
herrschen ohne Ordnung gibt es keine
Freiheit in unserem Land muss Autorität
auf allen Ebenen wiederhergestellt
werden angefangen bei der Familie wir
müssen massiv in unserer Jugend
investieren um ihr einen festen Rahmen
zu bieten es besteht ein Bedürfnis nach
Autorität und Respekt ganz genau einzig
und allein wer in seinem Inneren
eigentlich gegen die harte Hand ist weil
sie nicht seinem Naturell entspricht
darf sie anwenden wenn du auf diese
Weise kann garantiert werden dass ihr
Einsatz nur dazu dient das Gleichgewicht
wieder herzustellen ich dazu ins andere
Extrem umzuschlagen also es liegt voll
und ganz in der Verantwortung der
gemäßigten die eiserne Faust in die
eigene Hand zu nehmen Sie auf keinen
Fall ihnen zu überlassen die in ihren
Herzen und im Kern ihre Gesinnung mit
dem Autoritarismus oder gar den
Totalitarismus sympathisieren ob mit den
nationalistisch völkischen rechts oder
links kollektivistischen oder dem
religiösen sie alle versprechen zwar den
jeweils anderen Teufel auszutreiben
wollen ihn aber letztlich nur durch ihre
Version der Hölle ersetzen im Laufe der
Krisen Schaukeln sie sich gegenseitig
hoch bis eine Kraft von ihnen die
absolute Macht an sich reißt und allen
anderen ihre Freiheit nimmt aber wie
genau der Weg zu einer wirklich
zielführenden Politik zur Rettung
dadurch diese Gefahr bedrohten
europäischen Ländern ausgestattet sein
könnte werden wir uns in zukünftigen
Videos ansehen vergesst also bitte nicht
das Abo unbedingt mit Glöckchen um sie
auf gar keinen Fall zu verpassen und bis
dahin spielen wir den Ball erstmal euch
zu wie würdet ihr die Probleme
Frankreichs angehen gesunde Einwanderung
ist unverzichtbar und hat zudem sehr
positive wirtschaftliche Auswirkungen
aber wie können wir die Integration der
ersten und vor allem der zweiten und
dritten Generation von Einwanderern
verbessern stimmt ihr mit dem überein
was wir gesagt haben und wie sieht es in
eurem Land aus wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem sicher Kontroversen
die kritischen Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
etwas dabei gelernt haben falls ja gibt
uns bitte ein Like und teilt es mit
euren Freunden um auch mit ihnen darüber
diskutieren zu können natürlich wollen
wir uns auch jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch mit uns bringt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video vergesst
bitte auch nicht auf unserem neuen
discord Server vorbei zu schauen der
Link befindet sich ebenfalls in der
Videobeschreibung also man sieht sich
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]